hello everyone and welcome back to the
semifinals of the feeder Grand Prix
being played in Hamburg it's the new
global versus young shift of Duda and as
we already mentioned two of the
classical games have been drawn then
dubov took the lead by winning the first
rapid game and now do that is in a
really terrible situation he's in a
must-win situation against above and he
has the black pieces so here you have to
play something not not commonly you
can't really use your your main weapons
as of course Du Bois prepared for them
and it's just well just a terrible
position to be in and but I mean there's
a lot at stake of course if you don't
know now two of the two of the best
players of all the Fida Grand Prix's and
the final standings will be granted two
spots in the candidates tournament 2020
so a lot on the line and well it's not
going to be easy but you still have to
face Alexander Grayson in the finals
after this match whoever wins it so
let's see how this game went do both
with the white pieces opens with d4 we
have g6 the so-called modern defense we
have E for Bishop to g7 Knight to f3 and
d6 still waiting with the development of
the f6 Knight with Bishop to c4 by dubov
and now a six again this has the this is
played even under on the top-level
Knight to f6 is the most common move
here but a6 is a much rarer move and of
course it is what to do that will try to
use against dubov so with castles by the
one just links all moves very principled
moves taking the center developed a nice
before Bishop Bishop Anna well on a very
active square get your King to safety so
if Duda is nothing any the real system
duo we'll just play very strong solid
moves with b5 are pushing the bishop
back preparing the ship to b7 with
Bishop to b3 Bishop to b7 and now a rook
to e1 and this position has been reached
before but e six the move do the place
is a new move in the position so as a
most seven we have a completely new game
we have c3 and just strengthening the
center and Knight to d7
with a for attacking a more central pawn
with a less
born with a four and not Knight to f6
finally Knight B to d2 by dubov and now
do the finally castles with the shabak
the c2 and now c5 striking in the center
and here nice to f1 re maneuvering or
the night over to g3 we have Queen to c7
developing the Queen connecting rooks
and not night the g3 rook F to c8
probably with the idea that if if pawn
captures on d4 pawn captures you will
have a nice Queen rug battery along the
open C file so Bishop to d3 now and
before you have to create some
imbalances in the position you are in a
must-win situation with black with a 5
by do both grabbing more space on the
Queen side and now even c4 with Russia
back to f1 and not B 3 so it's a it's a
nice chain probably d5 is coming and
then you will have a really huge pawn
chain but it's it's hard to say if this
is good or bad for black if you push d5
danger bishop on b7 is not gonna be not
gonna be an awesome piece it's very hard
to say when it will be able to enter the
game but dubov makes sure that that he
has to close that close it and you can
do it with sounds like night to d2 as
the bishop from f1 already attacks the
c4 points you just add another attacker
and well you kind of don't want to move
the Queen away from there at and it's
not really useful EU have to add another
defender to the point but Du Bois uses
rook the a4 instead now threatening rook
captures and c4 and here
d5 just getting that defender in there
and now comes a 5 so knight back to be 8
and here if you look at the position
it's it's a very nice pawn chain there
is no arguing that that is a beautiful
point chain but if you also look at the
position all of black's pieces are cut
off by that exact same point chain from
from the defense of the black king so
now duo says okay it's time to start the
attack he pushes h4 bush of the c6
pushing the white room back look back to
a 1 and now rook seat the b8 just
preparing rook the b5 at some point this
could be a liability if it worked to b5
the Queen already attacks the f5 pawn
you
might be able to pick it up and if you
can start pushing your upon maybe black
can do something about this
so with h5 and now comes Luke the b5 s
plant and here we have Knight to g5 also
possible was just h6 first and grabbing
even even more space and after Bishop to
f8 now go Knight to g5 would be a very
solid position for white because you
still can't capture here because just
Knight captures and on e6 would pick it
up as this comes with an attack on the
Queen but to Bob's idea is Knight to g5
first he's going after the weak f7
square Queen to f3 followed by Queen f7
it is the way to go but it's not a
problem as after this Knight moves the
Queen card covers the f7 square so nice
the f8 and here Queen to f3 just putting
the Queen into the attack mode here f7
is threatened not threatened but you
know the black has to be very careful
because the Queen has to keep an eye on
the f7 point but also on the bishop here
for example if the Queen moves away from
the defense of the bishop you can just
play Bishop captures on c4 and if if the
pawn captures then Queen captures and c6
the Queen is the only one defending the
bishop here so look the a7 adding
another defender to the f7 point and now
Knight to h1
there was a there was the possibility of
Knight to h3 right away for example if
root captures an 85 now rook captures
and if I now was is impossible because
of the the idea that we've already shown
Queen captures Bishop captures here just
picks up the the piece on c6 but do both
first plays Knight to h1 with h6 now
pushing the knight back and not nice to
h3 preparing to bring the night into the
game either via Knight to f4 or
depending on what black plays but there
was also a possibility instead of
removing the Knights to just play H
captures on g6 which creates a really
crazy line
pawn captures on g5 and now Bishop
captures on c4 and the rook is under
attack so once you capture the bishop
you open up an attack a towards the
Queen but now Khan captures on f7 with
check and if you move the king then
Queen to h5 is deadly so you have to
after it and now Queen character son and
c6 and now okay black is up black is up
a piece but black has a lot of
weaknesses here this is a weak point
this is a weak point this is a weak
point this is a weak point so you will
grab more material here and white will
be preferred here even though you're
down a piece as those rooks for a moment
are not to doing all that much but it's
maybe too exotic of an idea for Du Bois
who only needs the draw to proceed into
the finals against Alexander Grisham so
tonight back to h3 and not g5 just
closing any attacking ideas and now
dubov prepares to push the f4 point
Queen to g3 is one option you could just
align the Queen with the King and then
push f4 but do prefer squinted b1
instead for some reason not sure why I'm
sure there's a good reason but nah not
really sure maybe maybe if the Queen was
on g3 maybe maybe f5 and then if
captures and Poisson it would create a
possibility for a queen trade which my
dubov might want to avoid as well it
without the Queen's on the board the
black's pawn structure is better due to
the this pawn already being on b3 bulky
rook captures an a5 we have rook
captures on a5 Queen captures an a5 and
now f4 trying to open up lines in front
of the black King and here g4 do the
offerors upon and dubov doesn't capture
it pink a person g4 is the strongest
move recommended by the engine and it's
hard to see why you wouldn't want to
capture this point it just seems like a
very nice pawn but the problem is
probably if f5 then if you move the
Queen you don't really have any more
attacking chances black just completely
stopped your attack and he has a past
tape on he's gonna move the Queen start
pushing this pawn create a path beep on
probably this is why but again it's it's
what it's what the engines recommend but
it's it's hard for for a human to play
it so of course Du Bois doesn't play it
he he plays Knight 3 back to f2
he says ok I can always recapture with
the night we have f5 now and now this is
a very solid structure so you
allow that you know to exist we have
each captors nf6 um Poisson night
captures and now night to g3 we have
looked f7 and Bishop to e2 now adding
another attacker to the g4 bond and
preparing to capture it with Russia back
to d7 and now Knight captures on g4 with
Knight captures energy for Bishop
captures and now Queen to c7 preparing
to well bringing the Queen back into the
game and Knight to e2 adding another
defender to the f4 pawn here and now a5
do that starts pushing his a pawn and
here we have a sari with f5 duo again
with a very nice pawn sacrifice clears
the f4 square for his pieces so he can
start grabbing even more square squares
he captures an f5 by Judah with Bishop
to f3 now threatening to pick up the d5
pawn bishop to c6 defending it and now
Bishop f4 just a very nice idea this
pawn sacrifice to frame the dear
Foursquare to develop his pieces Queen
to d8 and now Queen to c1 doubling up on
this diagonal preparing to capture on h6
with King to h7 and now Bishop to e5
offering a trade of dark square Bishop
s' Knights the e6 and now Bishop
captures on g7 with rook captures and g7
and mountain Knight to f4 offering
another trade and well you don't kind of
want to trade this only activates whites
Queen whites Queen is pretty much doing
not doing all that much on c1 so Knight
back to g5 and here
quinta III trying to get the Queen into
the game and here Duda goes for Queen to
d6 the Queen to d6 comes up with a very
sneaky idea if white isn't careful for
example if white plays something like
Ruby - let's say he makes a move do you
see what to do this poisonous idea was
I'll give you a couple of seconds if you
wanna maybe support it so for those of
you who spotted the poisonous idea
congratulations you are an excellent
spotter of poisonous ideas and for those
who just want to enjoy the show its
Queen captures on f4 due to the pin
along the G file after this
Unitas three check picks up the Queen
and you just want a piece King moves you
just capture the Queen and you are up a
knight so completely winning of course
Google sees this he doesn't allow it
Knight to g6 a very very nice square for
the knight you have to be very careful
here
rook the g3 Duda infiltrates the
deposition with the Queen and now rook
the f1 so the Queen can move the rook on
a1 will not remain a target and also it
adds another defender to the bishop here
rook to f7 preparing to push the F pawn
and now Queen to e5 Deauville now says
okay this is getting out of hand I have
to trade Queens here this is a very
dangerous here and you don't really have
an option if you push something like f4
you're getting made it quint h8 is made
so you have to trade winds here but du
Bois first decides to capture sorry do
that decides to capture an f3 with check
first so trade everything going to
Roxanne game with rook captures an f3
Queen captures on e5 Knight captures on
e5 with a double attack here and the
bishop and the rook and although I will
mention instead of capturing with the
knight capturing with the pawn loses the
game but it's very interesting because
it seems like you're threatening to
advance the pawn then advance it even
further and who knows what can happen
but d4 is winning for black the point is
after East 6 attacking the rook which
you don't mind trading rocks because if
pawn captures f8 Square is covered by
the night and it's a dark square black
will be unable to stop it but Ruby g7
ruins your plans now if east 7 of course
you're just gonna capture that you don't
care tonight captures and now everything
loses if Bishop captures on f3 you just
played G captures and if sorry if better
captures G captures you just play
capture son c3 and if B characters b2
becomes a queen so not possible but it
is interesting so I decided to mention
it but Knight captures both rook and the
bishop are under attack rook to f6 and
now Knight captures rook captures and
rook captures on f5 and after all of
this insanity we have a broken game
where both players have 5 points so this
is a probably a table base
but Duda cannot accept a draw as if he
accepts the draw he's out of the out of
the Grand Prix so we have a for Luke to
f7 check we have King back to g8 and now
comes Luke back to a seven going after
the a for pawn and not rooked a six Duda
allows the capture of the e4 pawn he has
to start giving some material if he
wants some activity and maybe maybe some
sort of a hope on how to win this
completely drawn rockin game so if rook
captures you're going up to e2 which
will pick up the beat beat upon white
cannot I love this so do both ghost King
to f2 we have Luke f6 check and now King
to e 2 we have looked at 5 going after
the h5 pawn now upon is traded captures
captures and not look back to a-1
preparing to bring the rook into the
game from behind
rook to g5 attacking the the Jeep on and
now king of three just defending it rook
a 5 check King to e2 and came to g7 now
do that starts bringing the king into
the game so it's three pawns each on the
Queen side and upon each on the Kings
side with King III and now h5 everything
is nicely protected there are no targets
in the position this rook cog guards
both pawns we have King back to e to do
both is of course very happy with that
if if Duda is very happy with that with
King to g6 and now rook back to a 8 rook
to f7 and now rook the a5 going after
the pawn here and looked at d7 now so
here do go just says okay I'm attacking
your d5 pawn you either have to defend
it or if you bring the King over to help
out the defense of that I'm just gonna
bring my king over here maybe maybe grab
the h5 pawn let's call this the call
this a draw and I'm gonna go to the
finals but after King to f3 we have King
to g5 and now g3 and here look the d8
still not much happening on the board we
have Brooke to be 5 and here look the f8
check King to g2 and here comes the
magic move King to f5 this is what do
the tries he decides he's gonna give up
this pawn with check and also offered
this pawn so he will
perhaps get some sort of a position
where he can ask for more than a draw
and this is very dangerous stuff you
know or a gambling like this because uh
we'll although if you accept a draw you
don't you're out the Fida Grand Prix but
if you don't accept it or if you give
two pawns in a rooks end game well you
can just lose the game although do then
do the understands that losing a game
here is much less relevant than actually
winning the game if and if any how
possible so rook captures and if I would
check duo of course grabs that kink the
e4 and here
dubov makes a mistake rook captures and
h5 is the way to go it seems odd
grabbing a pawn right away you know when
is that the correct path to take the
problem is after King to e3 you go rook
the h2 right away and now white is in
time to defend the be to pawn for
example if you start going there with
your king you can just move the king and
the rook protects the the back rank and
the black can't really afford to trade
rooks with rook after check you're just
gonna move the King and now after
captures captures it's actually white
who's winning due to the past be pawn
and the black is too slow so we have
rooked instead of capturing which is
great for duble he plays rook to e5 and
this is a this is a game-changing tempo
that allows do that King to d3 and now
how do you how do you get the rook into
the game to help out with the defense
you really don't
so here do both played d5 but now King
to c2 going after the b2 pawn we have
looked at each check and now King the c1
is is a better move than King to d1 but
both are very low on time as King Tut
King to c1 prevents the roof from ever
moving you cannot read you the D to
square the King covers it to put the
room behind the passport and also if you
move the rook you're gonna lose the b2
and the c3 pawns but keep the d1 pushing
the roof back and the now comes Luke the
e5 rook to e4 was better as again you
can go after this capture but we have
looked the e5 going after the H pawn now
and now comes came to see one again
going after the pawn and here do both
again changes his mind
problem is if you go look the e2 then
look to d8 will be sufficient to pick up
the d5 pawn so we have looked for now
going after the c4 pawn instead of the
h5 point but it's it's much too late we
have looked to d8 there's always time
for this it's not rush it's important to
eliminate this guy here we have rook
captures on c4 rook captures on d5 and
now look the d4 offering a rook trade of
course a du du-de is not interested we
have looked the c5 and now c4 so what do
you do here King captures and me - of
course
and now Duda has a past beep on we've
looked the five again offering a roof
trade or rook captures and c4 fall by
rook a person h5 which happened in the
game so it's a rocks endgame one point
each but this point is much faster to
the queening squared than this pawn so
King to c3
freeing up the the B file for for the
pawn to Queen you cannot go behind the
point because Ruby just blocks it so we
have looked at h1 but now b2 we have
King to h3 start preparing to push your
own past pawn but now King the b3 we
have looked to be one very important as
rook the rook to c1 is the threat if you
block the rooks attack towards the b1
square you can just queen on the next
move so look the b1 pretty much forced a
but now look the C one nonetheless
and here Du Bois was forced to play rook
captures and beat you with check King
captures and now we get this position
can is white in time to push this pawn
all the way and the pawn end King
because you have to sacrifice the pawn
for for your opponent's rook well give
up the pawn for the rook if you want to
draw this so let's see what happens if
you start pushing the pawn right away if
you start pushing the pawn right away
Ruby g1 now King gauge for you have to
help escort the pawn with the King King
c3
King g5 you have to also prevent the
black King from reaching the pawn king
before you're gonna go King to f5 now
we're gonna go King D v g5 came to these
six you're gonna go King to f6 but now
rook f1 check you have to go back with
the King to the G file King g7 now comes
King e6
you're gonna go g6 and now came to e7
King g8 you're gonna go Ruby g'wan and
now after pawn reaches the g7 square now
you attack it twice King f6 and now
finally after the King reaches the
corner now you don't capture otherwise
it's stalemate but you just push the
king and now it's game over either you
move the King and you captured upon
which check you continue to checkmate
the White King or you bring the Queen
into the game and not just check and
after two more moves it's a very nice
checkmate
so g4 doesn't work do the dubov tries to
go for King to g4 to activate the King
right away but King c3 with King to f5
and rook f1 check King to be 5 and now
comes look to g1 King to f4 guarding it
and knocking to d4 and it was in this
position that Daniel dubov resigned the
game and incredible but there you have
it
Duda is back in the match he equalizes
and they proceed to to another rapid
game which is just insane with the black
pieces in a must-win situation against a
wizard like do both this is a very
impressive victory by Duda and if you
know if you ever find yourself in a
completely drawn looks end game here is
your your proof that you know it can
happen you know things happen in chess
about yeah he he resigns as this is even
a worse position than the one we
analysed the King already reach the King
on the 4th rank so there's no way you
can do this and of course both of them
know this so that's the game Duda is
back in the match and we are gonna cover
more games from this match tomorrow
morning when I wake up as it's very late
and very tired so if you don't want
anything spoiled don't search for any
results you can just check it out in
tomorrow's video or if you're too
interested to see what happens you can
also just check the comments below
because all other people will comment so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Pavan Karim Shetty
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this match to see who we
should meet in the finals you know
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and still
continuing to decide on the next big
saga so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day